you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang buzz bug
sure
what's up brendan theo chris hey so uh i
got a debate club man uh what was
y'all's favorite game at recess or like
gym you know at recess my favorite game
was uh tetherball you know with the
pole yeah
you had to hit it around and [ __ ] yay
so let me know what y'all's favorite
game was man gang gang buzz buzz sword
nice oh we did the ham motion um okay so
what's this guy saying oh best game at
recess i'll take it fellas it's either
crazy kickball which you do don't know
[ __ ] about jesus crazy kickball you can
kick it you can run to first or third
and then you can join hands like rules
and hold each other until you get to the
second and first bases
[Laughter]
it's weird to be like if i was gay
though i would be i would be the top i
don't know i'm not gay i might like to
take it who knows but if i was gay i
might be walking backwards feeling like
let's go guys who knows
i'm not doing it i'm not doing it either
at the bottom no no
you guys you know what i've got any of
it no i don't want any part of this i'm
just saying
if i have to do it
daddy's top but that's because you're
you're thinking that as a straight male
as a gay male you don't know you might
[ __ ]
walk backwards right now dude i know
you you might moonwalk down melrose
to get it hey hey guys get in this ass
you don't know
get that ham slammed
um the other game i used to play and
hopefully you guys know this game no red
rover red rover know it and they'd go
red rover red rover send brendan right
over no and dude i would sprint like a
wedge buster on a [ __ ] football field
and plow through those kids holding
their stupid hands yeah but it was
always
like what kid took that game seriously
red rover red wrote see that's your
problem no no that's your problem
brendan no no electricity
thank you i don't take any game
seriously dude i didn't like to do it i
tried to take it seriously a little bit
and then i was like you know what bro
this is not for me yeah but your boy's
got the gift of gab
i'd roll up into the library and watch
these freaking kids play the games and
be like uh oh you know what this this
poor guy made a mistake he thought you
guys were cool no we are not he made a
mistake you guys were the nerds no i
wasn't the next you were the weird kid
staring at the wall i just said well
your boy played red rover red rover we
did kites at our school and we had a
kite thing after you tied it out
it was a racial tone
yeah
yeah oh oh tight tikes kite
we did kites and what else did we do oh
they had a map you could go on the
different kind of cities and countries
nobody played smear the queer red rover
red rover crazy kickball tag don't think
you could say that first one anymore
yeah they changed it it's also known as
rugby
oh
uh i don't know the rules of any of
those games
because you grew up rich no he never
played that right this guy hasn't had a
lot of j-o-y okay okay well i will say
this we did have uh tetherball
and we
always want football
and basketball all right dude you
are an alien
dressed up as a human right now just
saying the games that they told you
about when they told you to take over
the world and these are the [ __ ] yeah
those were the most popular games we had
baseball
we had baseball and hockey
if we were in if you went to school in
canada
what else so when it rained everybody
get out in the ditch and pick onions
pick those ditched onions
bring it up onions
do something since i have no idea why
we're paying you hey when it would rain
i would uh put my mouth in the gutter
and drink it oh that explains a lot
mm-hmm
nobody oh you i hate that joke though
yeah that's dung in it man you know what
happened you guys had water i didn't i
was the guy
yeah that's fine
i'll drink that piss dude
your bottom
[Laughter]
you know what's going on here it's a
terrible childhood huh no you're playing
heave roulette down there bottom dog oh
cause i'm drinking out of the gutter
nobody played or drank gutter or eight
no no no way dude i would i barely ate
my food together i'd separate it yeah
you're a you're a great you're a good
guy
but it is uh
you we shouldn't have been doing that
yeah dude i used to have my friends come
around i'd eat a red ant or a black ant
and i said the black ones look like
chocolate and the red ones taste like
cinnamon oh okay that's a lie
yeah but they didn't taste like that
right oh no it's a complete lie okay so
you'd like something i want them to try
this but you're still eating the eggs
can we start yeah
[ __ ] it gotcha got you
yeah you're an idiot yeah
i'm sorry
no i'm sorry you didn't have grass
stains on your jeans guys says cool
talking about drinking piss out of a
gutter and eating ants nobody's pissing
in the water dude i was up top it's
mother nature's piss we had ditch onions
that makes sense dude bring up a ditch
is real makes it worse don't be like see
no it makes me sad
you were in the rain looking for [ __ ]
onions
sad okay woody it's free vegetables man
we were doing good they're not even the
good oh you can't even break them off
and eat them and i'm the gay one for
drinking six-year-old's breath horrible
as [ __ ] go back to the original picture
why are you over doing it when you don't
do anything bro i know what i like and
one of the things i
veer away from
is digging for ditch onions when it's
raining yeah it's not one of those
things i have to experience to know i
don't like i'm not cause you don't have
a heart and you got no culture okay
that's not true the horn you've never
had you've never been out there in the
rain with your buddies and copped a
couple of [ __ ] free veggies homie
nah bro i don't when it's raining coming
out go inside you know i got caught a
couple juicy earthworms
you could eat them as a joke
you just
some gay guy sees you eating two ants
dude you're a bottom son
dude some guy sees you deep throating a
[ __ ] onion that looked like nuts out
of the gutter we brought them home to
our moms you my ass yeah they go like
this ah thanks yeah everyone was
thinking always raining again huh weirdo
they were good stop spreading your
[ __ ] nose out so you can breathe
dude wear a breath right here in here
let's go king and the sting in the wing
full circle and put on the whole team
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
[Music]